in arts and North Downs the alliance
party have made ground with a two-seat
gain the other major parties have
managed to retain their seats from 2019.
and in mid and East ancient the
Democratic unionist party lost the seat
while the Ulster unionist party gained a
seat
Shinn Fein doubled their Tally from two
to four seeds it means that Shin Fame
has secured 30.1 percent of the first
preference votes so far followed then by
the dup and the alliance party
the results will decide who will
represent voters across the 462 seats of
the 11 councils in Northern Ireland
our senior Ireland correspondent David
Blevins has the latest from Belfast just
a warning that his report contains flash
photography
the rise and Rise of shin Fein the
largest party at Stormont now the
largest party in local government
Michelle O'Neill says the dup should
respect that mandate and restore power
sharing allowing her to become first
minister at last there shouldn't be any
delays we should not be willing to the
Autumn to have stored executive and
assembly there's no reason for it not to
be setting tomorrow next week there's no
reason for any delay and the dup are in
a battle with the British government and
the people are the collateral damage in
the middle of that battle and that's not
acceptable it's not good enough
turnout was lower in unionist areas but
the dup says there's clear support for
its boycott of devolution over
post-brexit trading Arrangements the
dups
and I am not going to allow anyone to
sway to swipe aside at the voice of
unionism I will continue standing up for
unionism for Northern Ireland to fix the
problems that confront us at the moment
to ensure that our place in the United
Kingdom is not only respected but is
protected in law
most of the focus has been on the two
largest parties but there is a quiet
Revolution continuing in the Middle
Ground the alliance party which doesn't
designate as unionist our nationalist
cementing its position as the third
force in Northern Irish politics
but the alliance leader is worried about
some sections of the community
disengaging altogether ultimately if
people are sitting at home it's because
they don't feel that there's anything to
come out and vote for and I believe it's
important that people participate and I
would hope that other parties would be
concerned when they see sections of the
electorate not failing apart not feeling
motivated and not wanting to come out
and participate in the elections with no
devolved government in place many people
are disillusioned by the political
stalemate here things don't change so I
just expect the results are going to be
the same as they were last year I think
there's a sleeping giant in the middle
that's not
um this disengaged from Liberal politics
there is apathy and it's a shame but
there is a growing apathy
the more things change the more they
stay the same in a divided Society still
struggling to emerge from the politics
of them and US David Blevins Sky News in
Belfast